a stump what I think is probably the
mildest okay okay yeah we'll stop
chilling yeah yeah and even the most
chill yeah even then it was weird so I
got one which was uh name a hentai or
recommend a hentai that made me cry made
me sad yes and I can't remember the name
of this one it took me like 30 minutes
to even find the name and then I'd copy
and paste it and send it to you I think
it's called it's called
and does that mean follow me
yeah yeah what it what is it what's
mizuru K line is it the author I think
mizudu care is the author oh okay at
least that's what from what I remember
because when I when I looked at the
title I was like in Japanese I was like
that doesn't really mean anything it's
just like the name of the amusement park
yeah so I I guess I'll I'll explain the
the opening sure how this show Works
explain the premise of this shirt of
this okay so
um there is a land a theme park you
think of a uh you know your favorite
theme park now imagine if instead of
that and rides that you could ride you
could ride other people and the whole
aspect of this park was to sleep or
engage with fun activities with the
other people there yes and that was kind
of the premise and then two boys are
like yo let's go let's go let's go to
the land boys
however in real and then obviously we
also see uh two female characters who
are also interested one of them it was
three right yeah three one of them you
know they're all different personalities
one of them's a bit more shy but like oh
I don't know
like all right I'm ready I'm ready to
get down and dirty I'm about to go dicko
mode yeah like and so obviously in real
life this happened it would be a sausage
fest yeah actually turn into yeah a
grinder world yeah somehow it's uh
equally distributed in terms of like
both girls and boys yeah it's the most
well-managed theme park in existence I I
actually I actually made notes this time
that's good I wish I made notes I was so
annoyed I didn't want to write it I I
literally my first the first note I made
was finally a way to get Joey to enjoy
Disneyland
no he hates theme parks I hate
steampunks and I was like oh finally a
theme park that Joey and Joey would
enjoy let's let's talk the first five
minutes of this show okay I was kind of
I was kind of into the premise I was
kind of like I was kind of like I
thought yeah this I'm into this yeah
they explained they explained the theme
park animation was solid as well
I will say because like like going into
this obviously the categories are hentai
that made you cry and I was like this is
this is really [__] vanilla for like
where's the where's the crime coming man
where where is the crying come in and uh
yeah like like I was saying earlier like
you know some sometimes I I looked at
the show and I looked at the the
category I guess that a fit and I'm like
I don't know if I'm watching this
correct show yeah because I finished
episode one of this and I was like
what made me cry
I had the exact same reaction I was like
dude my my eyes were drier than a desert
there was not a single tear welling up
at one point does this make you feel
like sad not really dude I felt so empty
when I finished this I was like that is
the saddest [__] I've ever seen if
anything all the other shows made me
feel sad I I was yeah I would agree with
that okay okay okay but anyway yeah
let's explain the plot so so there's two
boys on a bus and there's three girls on
the same bus they don't know each other
yet all right but but the boys are like
yo tits out for the boys let's go we're
about to we're about to go dicko mode
and the girls are like all right you
know we got a friend who's like you know
hasn't done this before but you know
what we'll we'll ease her into this
stuff up yeah and uh the explanation in
the theme park and how it worked I was
like oh
this is legit like this is this is the
most this is the best management of
theme parks I've ever had yeah this
theme park runs better than Disneyland
does somehow they got an entire like
sticker system in this theme park you
have like three tiers so you can either
have like a sticker that says you're
okay with kissing uh there's a sticker
that says you're okay with touching and
then there's a sticker that says full-on
penetration baby let's go and of course
no one does the kissing sticker we don't
we don't follow kisses here everyone
goes for like full-on Deco mode right
here
um and then yeah and everyone's wearing
like the weirdest outfits oh yeah the
the dude's outfits were so strange I'm
like so bizarre because they're wearing
this like it the only thing the only way
I can describe it is like you know that
bikini that Borat wears yeah yeah they
were wearing that except imagine that
but the dick is just fully out and then
the one of the dudes wearing like
chapless pants yeah his ass is just out
or something it's just like all right
on the bus here do you know why I found
really weird so it was that scene where
they were like explaining what was going
in the theme park right and these dudes
are just having a normal conversation
and one of the dudes is just like
casually jacking off while he's like
talking to the other dude
he's just having a pro talk at one of
them best friend yeah
and I was like I was watching this I was
like this is just Next Level Onsen you
know this is what happens if you go to
another Circle
you're in the onset all three boys pop a
Viagra and one of them and we're just
like yo boy it hasn't been so far you're
tripping so far man so weird I was just
like it's like I think I think what made
it like I think well maybe kind of weird
is is how they explain the rules in a
way that would feel a bit more realistic
because a lot of hentai just doesn't
even bother trying to even remotely
explain the words yeah right they're
like you're in the same world except
this guy's a chat or something yeah yeah
I think that's what was kind of like all
right okay kind of I was kind of like
precarious but I was like all right well
this seems kind of okay speaking on that
though what I did find was kind of like
okay it's so good at my expectations a
lot it did it did a weird way
to go where it went this is the most
I've ever seen Connor analyze any piece
of media I think this is the first time
I've ever heard the word Connors about
expectations well listen it's a it's a
the thing with with modern day of this
kind of stuff if you watch let's say
live action Western of this production
yes yes yes yes
um you know exactly when you drop that
time bar you know roughly what you're
gonna be on when you let go yeah yeah
yeah with this one I was like where is
this going like what is I thought this
dude was gonna get some gonna go wild
that is not what happened that is not
what happened at all yeah so we have two
two different groups and the first scene
the main guy and the main girl did I
believe but yeah at this point it
doesn't matter yeah so the main gun the
main mean girl are both like kind of
like this is their first time in a theme
park and their friends are like veterans
they've been yeah and they're like the
kind of like yeah yeah yeah and so the
first the first big scene takes place on
a ferris wheel where what happens by the
way there's a brilliant [__] pun in
the Japanese version okay it shows up
because in in Japanese uh Ferris wheel
is called the kandansha right right but
they changed the kanji of Khan and dung
to normally it means like you know um
viewing uh spinning yeah yeah right in
this
they changed it still says but now it's
the kanji for Roth [__]
that's good it's like going to the
carnation
so the first scene is uh two random
people get on this ferris wheel in like
one two main characters yeah so so the
two main characters end up seeing each
other and they've seen each other before
they see they see each other briefly
um
yeah yeah
they see each other on the bus and of
course they meet on the ferris wheel
um and I think for like of course they
do the deed
um and I think for him he's just he he
is in the wrong [__] place man he's
in love with this girl this man went to
a soap land to look for a wife man yeah
yeah yeah he he like it's I think he
just instantly like Falls for this girl
yeah in the ferris wheel or even maybe
on the bus right yeah and they seem to
have some chemistry going together we
only see his perspective yeah we only
see yeah we only see his perspective and
you know it's all pretty I'd say vanilla
stuff not nothing I haven't seen out of
the ordinary it's just a casual casual
orgy every now and again you know there
is a casual there is there is a weird
scene before this where one of the girls
is getting their vaginas cleaned and I'm
just like that's one thing I wanted to
say right like so they explain like the
rules of the theme park right where it's
like oh you have to wear a sticker and
it's like and one part I thought was
weird was like okay so uh so that
diseases don't spread all the guys and
girls have to get checked and like the
girls have to get like cleaned out by
this like [__] special host and and I
just looked at that I'm like that's
copium because everyone knows by the end
of it you are diseased off yeah yeah
yeah I'm like there's no helping like
this is this is just like nothing's
gonna come out of this yeah look we we
this is a fantasy world everyone on
Craigslist have had money and they all
pulled together to make a Craigslist
location IRL yeah
um and so if things start getting weird
where it basically turns to a kind of
swingers party right there were like two
two of the groups yeah yeah one
experienced guy one is a girl and then
the two main people who are the girl and
the guy who can yeah the newbies yeah
yeah and uh through the throughout the
course of the show the girl turned from
like being this I'm a shy innocent cute
girl to uh yeah I'm I'm kind of like I'm
kind of like really perverted yeah I
kind of I'm secretly like this yeah yeah
it's uh it's she has two wolves inside
of it
uh and uh during the swinger scene is
when we see words we see the darker
Wharf inside of the second girl right so
they they both start off you know with
their respective partners that they've
found from this uh from this Ferris
wheel and then they start doing the deed
next to each other I knew where it was
gonna go as well yeah they basically do
a wife swap essentially yeah yeah and
he's and you know he the the main
character is having a lovely time of
course he's a bad this girl they have
chemistry together
and then uh and then the swap happens
yes they swap because one of I guess the
other two feel done and they're like
yeah swap yeah and you're like no
oh no this dude doesn't want to swap
yeah yeah
it's not what made you sad it made me
sad because
it's like you're watching porn but
you're watching like the realest like
saddest emotion where it's like this
dude is just in this situation he
doesn't want to be in listening to the
girl he likes one foot away from him
getting pounded and she's enjoying it
more with him yeah and she is with with
uh with the with the other guy sorry
himself yeah and it's like how am I
supposed to jack off to this like this
guy's just getting sat like this guy is
just distraught he's just realizing that
the girl he like fell for and the girl
he lost his virginity to yeah it's just
loving getting pounded by this other guy
yeah who's clearly way better at this
than him and he doesn't know and then
this other girl is like consoling him
the one who like was just had it rough
like that don't worry man some people
just like it a little chill don't worry
some people like it that you're a little
[__] you don't know what you're doing
and it's like this is just this is just
the saddest thing why am I why am I okay
now you put that into that context I
understand why this is in this category
how the [__] I should get off to this
when think it is dude this is like at
least if it was some absurd kind of
stupid plot I would be like all right
whatever but like it's just like just
sad like a sad thing that could just
well that could happen
is it a crazy that like we look at a
show like this and we explain a plot
like this and we're like this isn't
absurd
why are you trying to convey this yeah
like what do you get from this yeah
this the the thing that made me
uncomfortable about this is that it is
NTR this is essentially NTR but it's
it's it's it's soft enough it starts
vanilla and then kind of goes into it I
think it's at least with NTR I'm like
I'm like yeah this is just [__] this
is dumb this is just stupid and it's
like yeah yeah it's unrealistic but the
thought of liking a girl then maybe it
turns out she doesn't like you as much
as you thought that's the thing it's NTR
that hits a little too close if you're
like together like yeah they weren't
together
but the thing but the thing that hits a
little too close to home is that he they
weren't together but he liked that girl
a little too much and a little too
quickly you know he was out of his depth
yeah he probably shouldn't even been
there exactly like he knew he was gonna
get hurt yeah that's just sad it's just
sad how do you not how did you watch
that and be like I feel nothing how how
because I think I looked at it and I
compared it to every other NTR I've seen
and I'm like it gets sad
everyone can relate to the feeling of
maybe you liked someone yeah maybe they
turned out to like someone else yeah
right exactly I think that's a very very
a human thing that most people have
experienced I think the Saving Grace for
me is that it's only one episode so
you're not as invested in these
characters if that happened at like
episode three then I'd be like oh this
is my God this was a 15 minute episode
as well it's two episodes where the
second episode has nothing to do with
those characters no oh thank God yeah
um yeah but like yeah it's just like
this is so [__] sad man because it's
Charlotte I think the saddest thing is
that this guy is basically just having a
therapy session wow as his trauma is
happening next to him right there the
girl that he fell for is just like
having us she's having a time of hers
having the time of her life because the
worst thing is that she said oh you know
I like you as well you know I feel like
we have a connection and then five
minutes later she's [__] getting
railed by this other guy who's doing a
completely better job and and this
girl's just like oh don't worry are you
it's not the size of matters it doesn't
matter and I guess and I guess the extra
like sad part is that like that was his
bro yeah like like this is the dude
that's like yeah bro we're gonna have a
great time together
like hey man I I really like that girl I
really don't want to do it yeah but then
also like I don't know it's [__]
stupid it's such stupid
it is to me like it is framed in a way
that uh it it is kind of the guy's fault
for
yeah because like even like the girl he
fell for she said going to this place
looking for some looking for a
connection is gonna get you hurt because
people here are not here for that
[__] yeah it's totally awesome
sympathize because you kind of follow
him yeah and yeah you can you can all
sympathize with liking someone who
really didn't like it yeah yeah and then
what's the worst [__] thing
last thing is after this happens after
she finishes getting railed and
obviously has a better side of him in
front of him after all that trauma is
happening as well right he asks her out
oh yes that was just that was the
saddest thing I completely forgot about
that just I just lost I just yeah how
pathetic how pathetic do you have to be
to watch that feel those emotions be
like can we still please speed again
that's true yes no as as he's confessing
and like trying to trying to profess to
this girl that like no no like this is
legit like I actually connect with you
on an emotional level she's like would
you still love a girl who loves getting
[__] down by random dudes and he's
like hell yeah babe and I'm like don't
do it bro
I still love you like it's so pathetic
and it's so sad like Joe I wanted to
[__] cry after watching I'm like that
is the saddest [__] I've ever seen like
you know how pathetic do you have to be
and what what a skeptical and sad way of
viewing relationships like this this
this series was yeah yeah so if you made
this like what is why what's going
through your head it's it's like the man
huffed so much copium he could like Huff
the entire atmosphere of Earth like it's
he was I don't know what he was thinking
when he just said oh yeah I just uh
obviously just have a trauma I just saw
the girl get [__] down and let's let's
ask her out let's say yeah this is the
perfect time to confess my love to this
girl
okay yeah now when you put it in that
perspective it makes sense yeah how did
you watch that and feel nothing because
again my mind has just been corrupted by
all the NTR I've seen and I'm like it
can get worse I know and yes she's
[__] weird I gotta say it's not the
most [__] up thing I've seen it's not
the saddest thing I've seen but it was
just kind of like surreal no it wasn't
it wasn't too real followed a character
that you every I think it's the main
character right because I think we've
all known someone like that yeah yeah
someone who innocently gets into bad
situations sometimes and some someone
who maybe Falls for a girl a little too
fast yeah and you're like you you try to
tell him bro don't do it okay this is
bad for you don't do it and they do it
anyway oh also I just remembered as well
like after he confesses and like after
she does like all of the yeah but do you
still love me if XYZ and they decide to
have intercourse again then she's like
it's so funny we don't even know each
other's names
as he's inserting she's like I don't
even know you name that is weird and I'm
like bro you got everything out of whack
like everything is out of order here
yeah yeah honestly like I don't know why
she said yes as well I guess she's she
they're both they both suck yeah they
both suck as human beings yeah yeah like
yeah she's obviously I don't even know
if she's like consciously leading him on
this we've done this into a [__]
character study by the way the only
chatterness is the woman who got railed
and then just kind of like sympathetic
towards yeah yeah yeah she's yeah she's
like the only no the only the only Giga
chat in that show was the [__] blonde
girl who was getting [__] down by
three dudes at the beginning she's like
just just leave me be I'm good yeah I'm
good you guys go have fun you know at
least the girl was sympathetic to this
innocent kid you know and and and try to
like talk him down but at that point
it's like what what can you say what can
you say
he's these two friends too far gone I
don't know man I don't even feel like
she was being sympathetic she just
literally just did like a GG Nori like
yeah I mean happily like I did end up
watching the second episode as well yeah
which is very different just because I
was like Curious is there is there a
happy ending for the story there is no
happy ending to this story because it's
a completely different story right um
the second episode focuses on like a
group of Idols
one thing that actually impressed the
[__] out of me right is okay the the
um the premise of the episode is that
there's a group of Idols that perform at
this theme park and of course they have
a kind of like handshaking kind of event
except it ain't handshaking it is uh it
is digging down the dick and down event
where you get one minute per per
handshake or per dick Shake I'll say God
um but what one thing that really
[__] impressed me they made a full-on
Idol song for this man what they made a
full-on Idol song for episode two I'm
like where are you getting this
production values from man yeah like the
whole show looks amazing yeah yeah it's
really well done oh no yeah the
animation was good character designs
were good which makes me more angry
because it could have been a good MILF
one and so we got this it's always NTR
man yeah I think that's a good [__] but
one time where you're like where's queen
bee at yeah when we needed him most he
disappeared yeah like I did I didn't cry
towards this but I will say I didn't
feel it I just felt like I felt
impressed I felt it was literally the
the you know that that image that's
popular the one with the scribbledon
dude who's like oh yeah
yeah that's how made me feel like I was
just like dude now for me it was the
horse on the beach with the man yeah man
that's how I fell after that man very
much
come on so don't watch it yeah don't uh
don't don't watch that don't want that
one